[Music]  true story Donald Trump true story  Donald Trump called this gentleman the  most beautiful guy he'd ever seen  remember do you remember this do you  remember this okay that does it with  that kind of judgment he is unfit for  public all that that seals it for me um  no I actually said that about you called  into a show that I was doing raising  money for for charity and I and not only  did he pay me that nice compliment but  he wrote a check for 50 grand to my to  my church no sorry but I'm curious like  this is a guy who now is the most famous  right there he's in the most famous  person in the world and he has gone on  record as saying you are the most  beautiful man he's ever seen I think  look IIIi think it's possible I could  have a cabinet position yeah in the  Trump administration what would that  qualify on if you're the most beautiful  person or Terry of hotness  Secretary of banging yeah so there's no  end to what you could do